when the news of the bombing came out
it was a massive story in germany we are
following some breaking news coming to
us out of dortmund in
germany it was covered by all the media
outlets three roadside explosions
triggered at the same time last night
as the coach left its hotel in the south
of dortmund public figures commented on
it we should not
let them affect our life wherever it was
the media echo went far beyond dortmund
i think it was front page news in every
single big paper around europe
everyone thought of like a terrorist
attack and people were scared that
throughout the city in dortmund there
was
more attacks to be happening unbeknownst
to investigators
just after the bomb went off and the the
players of the team were
shell-shocked the person who had
masterminded the attack was actually
sitting
in the hotel eating steak and sweet
potatoes
my name is thomas rogers i'm the
journalist who wrote the article
the get rich quick scheme that nearly
killed a german soccer team
dortmund is a mid-sized city
in the western part of germany in a
state called
north rhine westphalia and it's a former
industrial city
that's kind of fallen on hard times in
the last few
decades it was severely bombed in the
war so the center of the city is quite
stark some of the few high points
include
its soccer team
[Applause]
my name is ike henning i'm a reporter
with bloomberg news and i'm a great fan
of borussia dortmund
dortmund fans are super loyal on all
match days the entire city isn't black
and yellow
it's like a religion i think more than
most german cities soccer does
play a very large role in the identity
of dortmund
[Applause]
in october of 2000 the bbb
became the first team in the bundesliga
to actually go public
salaries for soccer players in the
bundesliga have
gone up very dramatically with such high
prices they thought that by
by going public they would be able to
compete better with big teams like
bayern munich
unfortunately that didn't go too well
dortmund bought too many expensive
players high wages
and the club almost went bust in 2005.
the price of their shares it has
sometimes gone up but mostly gone down
since they made that decision
[Music]
so on april 11 2017
the team was staying in a hotel on the
outskirts of
dortmund match day is always special in
dortmund everyone is
looking forward to it the team always
meets in the same hotel ahead of matches
they stayed in this hotel in order to
have a kind of neutral
space before games so that they could
concentrate be sort of isolated from
distractions things like that
everyone was pretty optimistic they had
a chance to go really far maybe into the
finals
i was in the office and getting ready
for match day i was going to meet with a
friend a fellow dortmund supporter in a
pub
as always the fans are very excited
about matches
on that day they were heading to play
in the quarterfinal against a.s monaco
at signal iduna stadium which is in the
center of
dortmund shortly before
7pm the players of the team boarded
their official team bus
when the bus took off the parking lot of
the hotel
and turned on the street were three
three detonations
three bombs that exploded and hit the
bus of dortmund
three explosions occurred close to the
borussia dortmund team bus
the b team bus had just left the hotel
the explosions destroyed two windows in
the rear part of the bus
people screamed people jumped to the
ground
the fellow doppman fan i was supposed to
watch the match with
he called me and said turn on turn on
the tv there was an attack at the
dolphin bus and i thought he was like
that was
impossible
some of the players screamed at the
driver to keep driving as fast as
possible because they were worried
that people might storm the bus german
investigators
say the explosive devices used in the
attack on the borussia dortmund bus
contained metal pins and that one had
pierced a seat headrest
unbeknownst to the team members the
actual
mastermind behind the attack was as they
were disembarking the bus
was actually eating steak and sweet
potatoes at the hotel they had just left
authorities are attempting to verify a
letter left at the scene
claiming jihadists were behind the
attack because there had been a series
of
attacks by islamic terrorists in germany
and europe
there was a widespread suspicion in the
media that this was another islamic
terror attack three letters were found
at the site of the bombing that took
credit
uh for the attack on behalf of islamic
state there were however reasons to
to doubt this particular narrative would
actually be a surprise
um if isis um were actually
um part of this this attack possibly
could be
um employed by other groups like the far
right wing to try and shift the blame
the letters had some strange qualities
they were written in a strange
german that used big sophisticated words
but had basic grammar mistakes as if
someone was native german speaker but
pretending to
be a foreign person federal
investigators have detained one man
suspected of links to islamist terrorism
one of two suspects whose apartments
were raided this morning
shortly after the the bombing a man in
austria named rudolph who is a was a big
bvb fan he noticed that something
strange was going on on the stock market
related to the team's shares
he emailed the lawyers
of bvb who then forwarded that email on
to investigators
the email stated that someone had bought
60 000
bvb put options a wager that the value
of the shares
of the team would fall below a certain
amount at a certain date
why would someone buy that ahead of a
match and then
three bombs go off something something
something isn't right here
for the person to make money off of that
to require the stock to go
down quite a bit in a fairly short
period of time and it wouldn't just be
the team losing a match it would require
something much bigger than that
there was another big red flag about
this purchase which is the fact that it
had actually been made
number one on the day of the bombing but
also from an ip address that had been
traced
to the actual hotel where the bombing
had taken place
when three explosions targeted the bus
carrying the borussia dortmund
footballers on april the 11th
written notes left at the scene claimed
the attack was the work of isil
the truth as is now alleged is
remarkable
on april 21st the police arrested a man
in a southern german city called
tubingen he was on his way to work
and his name was sergey venagold he
seemed like an unlikely suspect
because he had no known connections to
the
islamic terror world he didn't seem like
a
far-right extremist he didn't seem like
a left-wing extremist either
he seemed to be a completely
unremarkable
young man a 28 year old german russian
man
named only as sergey w stayed in the
same hotel as the players on the night
before the bombing
he specifically requested an upper room
overlooking the bushes where the
explosive devices were hidden
the media dissected why he would do that
what was his past
he had been inspired by the 2015
terror attack in paris and he noticed
that in the aftermath of the attack the
stocks of french companies went down
and he believed that if an attack
took place that was directed at a
specific company
that the decrease in stock price would
for that company would be
even more dramatic it never occurred to
anyone that
someone would do that out of greed we
now know that the suspect bought three
different derivatives on the borzia
dortmund shares
with all these derivatives he bet on
falling shares
the suspect bought the majority of these
financial products on the 11th of april
the day of the attack if the plot had
been completely successful and the stock
had reached a value of zero
inner gold would have made up to 570
000 euros or the equivalent of about
608 thousand dollars ultimately the
plan completely backfired the attacker
sergey benegold didn't make any money in
fact he lost money
in court he would be extremely quiet
he usually kept his hands clasped
together
one of the lawyers actually commented
that he had never seen
a defendant act so calmly
vaynergold had served some time in the
german military
from that information and from online
research he was able to
figure out how to assemble
remote detonated bombs that would do
what he hoped to do
there were a few days of extremely
emotional testimony
including the soccer players who
described
doubting whether or not they could ever
play another game again
it brought everything back up and it
didn't quite help them
to kind of process what was going on
throughout it all he sat there
completely
silent the big mystery that was
swirling around the trial was the
question of why
he may have simply done it because he
wanted to
impress a woman rebecca
is a young woman who has a very troubled
home life
she ultimately sees her relationship
with
vaynergold as an opportunity to leave
that troubled home
vayner gold is a russian immigrant to
germany
he speaks with an accent he has anxiety
in large groups of germans she begins to
resent the fact that
he has these fears and feels a little
bit trapped
rebecca attempts to dump him on multiple
occasions
and he threatens to commit suicide if
she leaves him
vaynergold apparently told rebecca that
she would soon be
seeing a surprise after being dumped
via text message he apparently began
planning for this attack in earnest
vandergold was charged with 28 counts of
attempted murder
which carried a maximum sentence in
germany of life in prison
he claimed that he had nothing to do
with the attack but as time went on
he admitted that he had actually been
the person who had built
the explosives and had set them off but
he claimed that he didn't want to
actually kill anybody
ultimately vayner gold didn't receive
the harshest possible sentence
he was given 14 years in prison but it's
still
a considerable amount in in jail in
[Music]
germany
you